en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología y debido a la
emergencia que vivimos a causa de la
pandemia de kobe 19 nos adaptamos desde
nuestros hogares para llevarles toda la
información
-soy valentina torres sánchez gracias
por acompañarme en esta ocasión
iniciamos hablando de kobe 19 porque
sabemos que hay numerosas vacunas y
otros medicamentos que se están probando
en el mundo hasta hallar tratamientos
seguros contra el virus en medio de esos
análisis que incluyen a miles de
voluntarios se han presentado efectos
adversos con algunos fármacos es el caso
de la candidata a vacuna de la compañía
johnson y johnson se encuentra en etapa
3 pero las pruebas fueron suspendidas
debido a lo que llamaron una enfermedad
inexplicable en uno de los voluntarios
aunque para muchos se trata de un hecho
preocupante los expertos aseguran que
los efectos secundarios pueden aparecer
en cualquier etapa de análisis y que la
suspensión del ensayo clínico es una
muestra de transparencia que debería
aumentar la confianza del público
en estos productos
este es un procedimiento estándar
muestra que el sistema está funcionando
muestra que la gente está siendo muy
cuidadosa con los voluntarios creo que
no hay que sacar muchas conclusiones
porque como digo estas son cosas que
pueden pasar las pausas
los responsables de la vacuna indicaron
que hay una junta de monitoreo
independiente que está investigando lo
ocurrido para establecer si el fármaco
es el responsable de la enfermedad del
participante ahora esta no es la primera
vez que se suspenden los ensayos
clínicos de una vacuna contra el hobbit
19 ya la candidata de la universidad de
oxford considerada una de las más
prometedoras tuvo que ponerle pausa en
las pruebas luego de que dos
participantes se enfermaron además el
producto de johnson y johnson no es el
único cuyo estudio fue pausado en los
últimos días el laboratorio y la unl y
lleva a cabo el análisis de un cóctel de
anticuerpo similar al que se le
suministró al presidente de donald trump
para el ensayo quedado suspendido por
potenciales preocupaciones de seguridad
mientras que las pruebas de estos
fármacos quedan frenadas en hong kong
científicos indicaron que un tratamiento
antimicrobiano mostró que es efectivo
para tratar el kobe 19 por el momento
las pruebas se han realizado en ratones
para evaluar la eficacia antiviral del
citrato bismuto de ranitidina usamos el
modelo de contagio en hamsters con este
modelo pudimos monitorear la carga viral
en los tejidos del tracto respiratorio
superior e inferior de animales
contagiados los hallazgos muestran que
tras el tratamiento con grandes civil y
ranitidina la carga viral estaba
notoriamente disminuida en particular la
ranitidina es capaz de bajar la carga
viral en el pulmón del hámster
contagiado
los investigadores destacaron que faltan
pruebas clave que determinen si el
tratamiento actuaría eficazmente en
humanos pero resaltaron la importancia
de encontrar un fármaco como éste que
está ampliamente disponible y su costo
es bajo
cambiamos de tema y hablamos de los
últimos anuncios de apple fueron
presentadas las cuatro versiones de su
esperado iphone 12 todas ellas equipadas
con 5g algo que era considerado una
deuda de apple pues hay múltiples
aparatos en el mercado que funcionan con
esta tecnología
veamos con más detalle el iphone 12 con
5g tiene un diseño completamente nuevo
que es impresionante tiene bordes lisos
y planos lo que permite que el marco de
aluminio y el vidrio permanezcan
alineados por delante y por detrás
creando esta construcción uniforme única
por dentro y por fuera el iphone fue
rediseñado para incluir nuevas
tecnologías en un factor de forma más
pequeño el iphone 12 se diseñó teniendo
en cuenta la tecnología 5g incluida la
posición de todas las antenas nuevas que
rodean el marco de aluminio ground y el
número frame el gigante de cupertino
indicó que ya su modelo anterior el
iphone 11 tenía la cubierta de vidrio
más resistente de la industria hasta ese
momento pero esta nueva versión cuenta
con algo llamado escudo de cerámica que
mejora su resistencia
por lo que según los responsables hace
que el teléfono sea más duradero los
cuatro modelos presentados del iphone
son el 12 el 12 min y el 12 pro y el 12
promax estarán en las tiendas
estadounidenses a partir del 13 de
noviembre y los precios en sus versiones
básicas irán entre los 699 dólares y los
mil 99 dólares
y finalizamos este espacio en ecuador
porque este país inició un plan piloto
para repartir mercancía con el uso de
drones la iniciativa que surge de una
alianza entre la empresa emergentes y la
luz y la aplicación de domicilios rapid
va desde quito hacia los suburbios y
tiene un alcance de 30 kilómetros el
plan tendrá una duración de entre 3 y 6
meses en los que se buscará completar
200 entregas y comprobar la viabilidad
de realizar estos domicilios con estos
aparatos no tripuladas la viabilidad
realmente hoy por hoy de que un dron
recoja en el restaurante y deje en la
casa no estamos todavía ahí entonces
somos el único que está trabajando un
modelo aterrizado realista que cumple la
funcionalidad de reducir los tiempos de
reducir las distancias pero que a la vez
cumple con los requisitos operativos
para tú poder volar drones para poder
hacer estas entregas este concepto
diario loops donde el dron vuela de un
espacio controlado a otro espacio
controlado y son personas repartidores
quienes están haciendo esta última misma
única alternativa que volvemos que es
realmente viable y escalable así
concluimos esta crónica cuídense si es
posible permanezcan en casa recuerden
que la salud es lo más importante
gracias por su compañía y continúen con
más en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]